bonjour à tous merci de me retrouver en
direct sur public sénat un an après les
assassinats commis par mohamed merah à
toulouse et à montauban les sénateurs
interroge cet après midi manuel valls le
ministre de l'intérieur sur la stratégie
française en matière de renseignement et
de lutte contre le terrorisme ont
rejoint tout de suite à l'hémicycle pour
cette séance série dispose de la
possibilité de recruter les personnels
compétents
ceci n'est pas forcément compatible avec
le fonctionnement et les procédures
actuelles
quelles dispositions comptez-vous
prendre monsieur le ministre à cet égard
je vous remercie tous bien merci d'abord
l'état monsieur manuel valls ministre de
l'intérieur merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président en sueur je
connais évidemment votre implication sur
ces questions là et d'une manière
générale de toute façon et je m'adresse
à tous les sénateurs mais je connais
leurs convictions combien il est
essentiel que nous retrouvions à la fois
pour tirer les enseignements de ce qui
s'est malheureusement passé il y a un an
les décisions que nous avons annoncé un
certain nombre de réformes structurelles
qui concerne la des séries visé je vous
réponds très directement à rendre plus
cohérente et plus efficace
l'articulation entre les échelons
centrales et régionales
l'organigramme de l'as des séries
intégrer une structure chargée de la
coordination opérationnelle entre ces
deux niveaux
je précise en outre que des bureaux
liaison été créé afin de faciliter les
échanges entre le renseignement
intérieur et l'information générale qui
elle même doit faire l'objet de réformes
tant au niveau central qu'au niveau
jaune à lanfains un service d'inspection
internes à la des séries a été créé
deuxièmement et c'était vrai parce que
c'était souligné dans le cadre du livre
blanc
il faut des moyens supplémentaires
financiers humains et techniques pour la
direction centrale du renseignement
intérieur dont je veux saluer
l'engagement et le travail face à
la menace terroriste mais ses moyens sa
spécialisation sur un certain nombre de
sujets sont évidemment tout à fait
indispensables
enfin même si rien n'est à ce stade
définitivement arbitré la question de
l'autonomie de gestion ne me semble pas
être un enjeu principal
il s'agit aujourd'hui de renforcer
d'abord les moyens en effectifs et en
investissement comme je viens de vous le
dire du renseignement intérieur et
autonomiser la des séries au sein d'un
programme
haddock sur laquelle il risquerait de
faire peser sur la des séries une
contrainte budgétaire plus forte et donc
je suis de ce point de vue là sceptiques
sur le fait qu'il y ait cette direction
a pas on enfin le débat est ouvert
je m'engage pas définitivement sur ce
sujet là ce qui est plus important pour
moi c'est l'efficacité de la des séries
merci très rapidement monsieur sueur
pour rattraper le temps passé
monsieur le président nous avons visité
récemment la des séries nous y avons
reçu un bon accueil et nous savons
l'implication de l'ensemble des
personnels que je veux à mon tour saluer
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie de
ce que vous avez dit quant à
l'accroissement des moyens que vous
projetez pour la des séries c'est
nécessaire et je voulais préciser les
choses quand nous parlons d'autonomie il
ne s'agit pas du tout de créer une sorte
d'état dans l'état ce n'est pas votre
souhait ce n'est pas le nôtre
il s'agit simplement de souplesse de
procédure parce que l'on voit bien qu'il
y à des dispositifs très précis très
formaté dans la police nationale en
matière de recrutement de promotion nous
les respectons mais nous savons que si
l'on veut être efficace il faut pouvoir
recruter des personnels qu'ils aient les
compétences requises dans des délais qui
soient raisonnables de telle manière que
l'on atteigne à la meilleure efficacité
c'est dans ce sens que nous avons parlé
d'autonomie et je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre votre réponse et pour votre
implication
monsieur le président merci la parole
est à monsieur vincent capo-canellas
pour le groupe
udi uc merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme les services
de renseignement joue évidemment un rôle
majeur
c'est vrai sur le territoire national
comme à l'étranger la connaissance du
terrain le renseignement sont
déterminants pour notre sécurité
dès lors se pose inévitablement la
question des moyens mis en oeuvre pour
cette lutte contre le terrorisme cette
lutte nécessite d'abord que les services
puissent agir dans un cadre juridique
clair ils doivent pouvoir disposer des
moyens judiciaires dans la quête et
avoir recours à des moyens
d'investigation adapté c'est le cas par
exemple des données financières et
bancaires que les professionnels du
renseignement devrait pouvoir obtenir
concernant certains profils afin
développer une action préventive il ya
lieu me semble-t-il de progresser sur ce
point peut-être faut-il s'interroger
également monsieur ministre sur la
situation juridique de terroristes
assigné à résidence dans notre pays et
sur les moyens de contrainte dont nous
disposons même si le cadre européen rend
toute évolution complexe la chute
récente du terroriste islamiste saïd
arif après d'autres doit nous conduire à
réexaminer ce sujet lutte contre le
terrorisme nécessite également le prises
en sus et revient à parler une bonne
coordination entre les différents
services
la réforme de 2008 qui a créé la dcr y
est positive il faut sans doute
poursuivre dans ce sens le constat du
manque de moyens notamment humains des
services français doit être posée les
effectifs et les moyens consacrés aux
renseignements reste malgré les efforts
bien inférieurs à ceux de nos voisins
européens ce constat il est vrai n'est
pas d'aujourd'hui
sur le plan des moyens techniques les
programmes de renseignement
électromagnétique pourtant essentielle
pour le recueil des données ont pris du
retard ou ont été reportés compte tenu
des évolutions technologiques et des
mutations des menaces terroristes
les services du renseignement doivent
pouvoir diversifier leur recrutement
renforcer leur expertise en faisant
appel à des profils spécifiques
linguiste notamment arabophone
psychologue analystes et d'image
monsieur mais il pouvait vous sur ces
différents points nous dire quels sont
vos orientations pour renforcer et a
même amélioré les outils détection de
surveillance et d' enquête des services
de renseignement je remercie merci
monsieur le ministre vous
ce président monsieur le sénateur j'ai
en partie répondu au président sueur et
j'approuve la plupart des remarques que
vous avez été amené à faire ce que nous
avons connu en france l'évolution du
terrorisme et donc de la menace les
événements de boston
il faut analyser parce qu'ils ont des
points de comparaison avec ce qui s'est
passé en france nous amène me
semble-t-il à nous dire que au fond le
principal frein à l'efficacité du
renseignement dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme réside dans les
cloisonnements cloisonnement entre le
niveau central et niveau local entre
services eux-mêmes
donc il faut gagner évidemment en
souplesse et notamment dans les
capacités de recrutement
et là vous avez dit des choses comme le
président sueur que j'approuve bien
évidemment enfin concernant cette
personne qui était assigné à résidence
que j'ai qualifiée effectivement de
particulièrement dangereuse jeu saïd
arif qui n'a pas respecté cette
assignation à résidence
je crois en effet que tout en respectant
nos règles européennes et nationales en
respectant la loi
il faut revoir ses dispositifs il ya un
certain nombre de personnes qui sont
assignés aujourd'hui à résidence et j'ai
demandé aux services de regarder avec
attention les propositions qui
pourraient même être faites notamment
pour ce qui concerne leur expulsion
merci monsieur le sénateur
merci monsieur liste de votre votre
réponse sur la question des moyens je
veux juste rappeler un principe que
chacun connaît si le renseignement coûte
cher l'absence de renseignements coûte
encore plus cher et évidemment on sait
tous que dans ces temps de disette ça
n'est pas simple mais qu' il faut
accorder de véritables moyens et sur les
questions d'ordre juridique vous avez
répondu sur sur le point particulier des
assignations à résidence je l'en
remercie mon souhait mon souci était
surtout de dire qu'il ya un équilibre
également à trouver
certes donné des moyens avait clarifié
parfois les règles mais surtout ne pas
alourdir parce que on peut aboutir temps
quand on discute des réformes de service
ou une forme de réformite qu'il faudrait
président dont il faudrait se préserver
ou bien aboutir à des systèmes
finalement quand on veut tout contrôler
et qui sont tellement lourd que
finalement on finit par ne plus utiliser
mais qui ne sont pas efficaces c'est un
peu les deux risque en tout cas merci
votre réponse très bien d'abord l'état
présent de la présidente eliane assassi
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre nous savons tous le terrorisme
et l'anéantissement des droits de
l'homme des libertés fondamentales et de
la démocratie et face à cette menace les
pouvoirs publics et la société tout
entière doit faire bloc
la lutte contre les menaces et les actes
terroristes ne doit souffrir d'aucune
indulgence
cependant et aussi pour lui donner plus
de force
elle doit respecter les droits et les
libertés fondamentales dont l'état est
le garant
ces droits durement acquis tels que la
liberté d'aller et venir ou encore le
respect de la vie privée ne peuvent même
dans des moments difficiles être
sacrifié sur l'autel de cette lutte sous
peine que soit porté atteinte au
fondement même de notre démocratie car
nous considérons que ces droits
accompagné de devoir bien évidemment
sont le fondement d'une sécurité humaine
durable et non un obstacle à celle ci
alors lors du débat sur votre projet de
loi de sécurité de l'ue contre le
terrorisme à l'automne dernier j'avais
rappelé que dans une loi du 23 janvier
2006 la droite alors au pouvoir avait
fait adopter à titre expérimental
une procédure de contrôle d'identité à
bord des trains trans nationaux et lors
du débat sur ce texte
l'ensemble donc le texte de 2006 à
l'ensemble de la gauche sénatoriale
alors dans l'opposition avait souligné
et je la cite et j'en étais et nous en
étions que cette disposition ne saurait
constituer une mesure destinée à lutter
contre le terrorisme et ouvertement une
mesure destinée à favoriser les
contrôles migratoires
fin de citation vous avez donc décidé de
proroger cette disposition lors du
projet de loi adopté en octobre 2012
donc en contradiction avec la position
de la gauche
alors et alors que le gouvernement
précédent n'a pas respecté l'obligation
de déposer chaque année un rapport
d'évaluation de ces dispositions comme
le prévoit l'article 32 de la loi de
2006 alors ma question est simple
monsieur le ministre
pouvez vous nous donner des éléments sur
la réelle efficacité de cette
disposition contre laquelle je le
rappelle encore une fois la gauche
sénatoriale a voté à plusieurs reprises
merci monsieur le ministre le président
madame la présidente assassines sur ces
questions là même si ça n'est pas
toujours facile il n'y a pas
d'obligation qui s'impose je crois que
nous devons essayer de converger de
trouver à chaque fois cette unité qui
contre le terrorisme doit s'imposer
après il ya des questions très concrètes
et vous en avez posé une j'y réponds
l'utilisation avérée de certaines lignes
ferroviaires par des réseaux
d'immigration irrégulière de criminalité
organisée ou de terrorisme confère un
intérêt évident à ces contrôles et il
constitue me semble-t-il parce que ces
réseaux sont des symboles forts de
l'intégration européenne des cibles
privilégiées et font l'objet de
fréquentes à l'air c'est l'un de ces
contrôles qui avait permis par exemple
l'arrestation en 2011 à modane par la
police aux frontières du numéro 3 de
l'organisation terroriste basque eta
la loi et d'une plus grande précision
pour se conformer aux exigences de la
jurisprudence de la cour de justice de
l'union européenne sur la finalité
et de ses contrôles d'identité et sur le
caractère non permanents et non
systématique de ces contrôles cette
mesure de prévention du terrorisme a un
caractère temporaire vous l'avez signalé
depuis son origine
le gouvernement est donc tenu d'en
solliciter périodiquement la progression
devant la représentation parlementaire
vous l'avez dit aussi c'est ce qu'il a
fait à l'automne dernier conte
présentant un projet loi assortie d'une
étude d'impact très détaillé il le fera
à nouveau en présentant le rapport
d'application de la loi
six mois après sa promulgation nous
approchons donc et le fera à nouveau
bien sûr au terme des trois années pour
poursuivre l'application de ces règles
le parlement est donc souvent est
complètement éclairer sur les conditions
et le bilan de l'application de cette
mesure
merci la parole à nouveau à madame la
présidente elle s'assit part dans ce jeu
vous appris c'est le président merci
monsieur le ministre pour c'est cette
réponse
moi je voulais insister sur le fait que
malheureusement les contrôles d'identité
ont jamais joué un rôle déterminant en
matière de lutte contre le terrorisme et
je nous trouvons que cette disposition
instaure un amalgame entre terrorisme et
une migration et c'est forcément un
amalgame inadmissible alors sur la
disposition soit allée expérimentale
elle fonctionne et donc dès lors elle
doit être adopté définitivement
soit elle est inutile au but poursuivi
est elle doit être abandonné pour se
concentrer sur les réelles solutions
voilà donc c'était un petit peu le souci
que je voulais il m'a dit bien entendu
ce que ce que vous venez de vous dire
donc nous serons amenés à redébattre une
nouvelle fois de ces questions là et
bien évidemment dès lors nous seront
disponibles en tout cas pour vous dire
encore un certain nombre de choses qui
nous oppose sur ces sujets là de
l'enfant tout cas j'espère que nous
pourrons aboutir sur des choses qui nous
rassemble
très bien merci la parole à madame
esther benbassa pour le groupe
écologiste et merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
en octobre dernier nous discutions dans
cet hémicycle du projet de loi relatif à
la sécurité et à la lutte contre le
terrorisme
ce texte promulgué en décembre 2012
n'était pas bien sûr sans soulever de
nombreuses questions et pour le groupe
écologiste notamment au regard du
respect des libertés individuelles
si une législation antiterroriste
efficace est nécessaire
il me semble en revanche qu'elle ne peut
atteindre son objectif que si elle est
accompagnée d'une politique volontariste
de prévention pour endiguer les mages
ans de ce fléau en france prévention qui
peut être multiforme et commencer dès
l'école de même l'obligation pour les
imams de suivre l'enseignement moderne
dans un établissement spécialement dédié
à cela
comme ce fut le cas au 19e siècle pour
les rabbins avec l'école rabbinique de
metz rapatrier ensuite à paris qui se
trouve actuellement à la rue vauquelin
la nomination d'aumônier d'aumônier en
prison ayant à suivre également
l'enseignement ad-hoc pour éviter la
propagation de l'islam ait lieu de
l'islam radical dans ces lieux
d'enfermement
ma question monsieur le ministre est
ainsi la suivante quel son parallèlement
l'arsenal législatives et à la création
de zones de sécurité prioritaire
les mesures que vous envisagez pour
prévenir efficacement toutes les formes
de radicalisation qui touche en premier
lieu des jeunes musulmans défavorisés
dans nos fameux ghetto merci merci
monsieur manuel valls ministre
l'intérieur monsieur le président madame
la sénatrice esther benbassa en
soulignant d'ailleurs que la question du
terrorisme dépasse largement la
problématique de l'islam radical puisque
pourront faire face aussi à d'autres
formes de terrorisme de l'ultra-gauche
d'ultra-droite le terrorisme basque que
j'évoquais ou venant d'autres régions
mais incontestablement il y a un défi
vous avez raison de le souligner la
question de la con
radicalisation même si ce n'est pas dans
notre vocabulaire est un vrai sujet il
est traité d'ailleurs au niveau européen
et je veux souligner de ce point de vue
là la qualité des travaux
impulsée par le coordinateur européen de
la lutte contre le terrorisme gilles de
cartes de carros je suis moi même j'ai
moi même participé à un séminaire sur
ces questions là parce qu'avec les
différents partenaires européens nous
essayons également de partager nos
analyses et de trouver en commun des
solutions l'école bien évidemment est un
lieu dans lequel nous pouvons travailler
la prévention de la radicalisation qui
passe par un contrôle resserré des lieux
de culte radicaux et la problématique de
la formation des imams va dans ce sens
et je vois que vous salue et de manière
tout à fait exceptionnelle ce qui avait
été engagé par l'empereur napoléon 1er
je ne vous connaissais pas cette
référence mais en tout état de cause des
choses ont été faites au xixème siècle
que nous pourrions retrouver pour ce qui
nous concerne
en ce début de 21e siècle et puis le
milieu carcéral parce que c'est un foyer
de radicalisation mais également un
travail de prévention au niveau de nos
territoires populaire de nos quartiers
populaires j'ai rencontré ce matin une
association qui travaille beaucoup sur
ces questions-là présidé par monsieur
denoix de saint marc parce que je crois
aussi que la société civile les
associations doit s'impliquer dans ce
travail
la répression est indispensable le
travail du renseignement aussi mais nous
devons mobiliser j'avais eu l'occasion
de le dire moment la présentation de la
laque pour lutter contre tout ce qui au
fond fermente prépare change un certain
nombre de mentalité et qui représente
une véritable menace pour notre pays
merci madame henderson
si vous le souhaitez vous savez la dette
d'accord avec moi puisque nous sommes
d'accord il faut mettre
il faut mettre en marche les les
modalités d'application de
de ces questions de prévention monsieur
le ministre
voilà merci monsieur jean-pierre placca
lanka de pardon pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues la politique de lutte contre
le terrorisme était un sujet essentiel
que le rdse a souhaité voir inscrit à
l'ordre du jour du sénat
pour cette séance de questions cribles
il est d'autant plus pour l'élu
toulousain que je suis maintenant après
les sept assassinats de toulouse et
montauban
nous sommes encore sous le choc la
fermera comme d'autres survenus depuis
je pense aux arrestations de marignane
ces dernières semaines a mis en évidence
s'il en était besoin que le
renseignement est un outil essentiel de
lutte contre le terrorisme en
coopération avec l'outil judiciaire bien
sûr là des séries direction centrale du
renseignement intérieur a été sévèrement
critiquée dans la cas dans le cadre de
la fermera je ne reviendrai pas sur ce
sujet sensible
mais mon groupe souhaite à savoir si les
moyens dévolus aux renseignements seront
renforcés et adaptée pour répondre pour
répondre au développement du terrorisme
de ce qu'on appelle souvent les loups
solitaires et dont les actes bien
qu'isolé ont des conséquences
dramatiques sur les populations civiles
et je ne voudrais pas non plus
stigmatisés parce que je pense aussi à
tous les extrêmes dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme
pensez aussi à tous les extrêmes de
droite comme de gauche et les extrêmes
religieux également ce terrorisme fait
maison suppose en effet une mobilisation
des moyens humains et technologiques
conséquent pour assurer la surveillance
de jeunes gens auto radicalisés et qui
se forment bien souvent via internet
si l' architecture générale du
renseignement a été repensé en 2008 ses
services n'ont pas été épargnés par la
rgpp
alors même que la stratégie de sécurité
nationale recommandé dans le même temps
un renforcement de ses effectifs et de
ses capacités techniques
c'est pourquoi monsieur le ministre je
souhaitais connaître vos intentions pour
améliorer l'efficacité de renseignements
un volet parmi d'autres de la politique
de lutte contre le terrorisme est un
volet essentiel au maintien de l'ordre
républicain auquel nous sommes ici tous
très attachés monsieur le ministre
sur le président monsieur le sénateur
jean-pierre plancade lactel ou font
peut-être le plus important au cours de
ces dernières mois pour lutter contre le
terrorisme a été adoptée par le
parlement
c'est la loi antiterroriste qui s'est
appuyé sur les travaux qui avaient été
engagés par le précédent gouvernement
qui était enrichie par le gouvernement
actuel
évidemment par le parlement et cela nous
permet aujourd'hui de poursuivre de
sanctionner les individus engagés dans
les filières djihadistes à l'étranger
que ce soit des ressortissants français
ou résidant en france et poursuites
judiciaires ou ainsi pu être diligentée
contre le français gilles le guen qui
vient d'être rapatriés pulsé ici en
france est prise en charge désormais par
la direction centrale du renseignement
intérieur il ya un travail qui est mené
qui est fait sur les filières du sel
syrienne un travail très attentif
même si évidemment il n'y a jamais de
risque zéro mais une mobilisation de
tous les services et de ce point de vue
là je le répète et vous avez eu raison
de le souligner faut être sur tous les
fronts le front du milieu carcéral nous
l'avons évoqué il ya un instant le
cyberespace parce que c'est
incontestablement là où beaucoup de
choses se noue et puis il ya un travail
de renseignement et pour cela la des
séries a besoin de mieux coordonner le
travail avec le niveau local y compris
avec ligier avec la dgse avec des
services étrangers a besoin de moyens
supplémentaires la des séries aura ses
moyens financiers supplémentaires des
moyens humains une capacité de
recrutement plus large pour gagner en
efficacité
la ferme ra est évidemment toujours
présente et nous pensons aux familles
des victimes aux victimes de ces
meurtres
et elle nous oblige tous un très haut
niveau de vigilance et d'implication
merci monsieur jean pierre plancade
c'est pas une réplique monsieur le
président c'était simplement pour dire à
monsieur le ministre que nous ne nous
étions pas de son engagement
déterminé dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme sous toutes ses formes passe
la parole monsieur roger karoutchi pour
le groupe ump seul candidat monsieur le
ministre on l'a dit et tout le monde l'a
dit donc je vais poursuivre la lutte la
prévention du terrorisme sont évidemment
des éléments qui dépasse largement tous
les clivages et eu des textes en 2006 en
2008 votre texte de loi de 2012 reprend
amplifie l'action conduite et c'est très
bien mais c'est vrai monsieur le
ministre que depuis quelques temps
travers de la ferme et ramé au travers
aussi d'autres affaires il ya eu un
certain nombre de critiques parfois
excessive sur les dysfonctionnements et
je voudrais dans un premier temps de
dire que la république de manière
générale doit rendre hommage à tous ces
agents des services intérieurs et
extérieurs qui risquent leur vie au
quotidien
sans toujours beaucoup de reconnaissance
mais qui amène la question aujourd'hui
c'est un rapport qui a été déposée la
semaine dernière
qui dit que en gros à la suite des
différentes études il faudrait pendant
un certain nombre de mesures avec par
exemple la création d'une inspection des
services avec par exemple une autorité
indépendante pour voir par exemple
quelle est la proportionnalité des
éléments mis à la disposition pour
obtenir des renseignements à l'extérieur
ou à l'intérieur
en clair on va devoir on va favoriser le
fait d'accéder à un certain nombre de
renseignements de mieux contrôler alors
la transparence elle a du bon parfois
mais elle peut être aussi un peu
inquiétante
elle peut être aussi un élément de doute
de danger pour les agents qui eux sont
en mission sur le terrain
alors monsieur le ministre ma question
est assez simple oui les renseignements
doivent être coordonnées oui vous l'avez
dit le lien des ges des séries oui il
faut renforcer les moyens de la des
séries mais quelles sont les mesures que
vous envisagez de prendre pour faire en
sorte que au travers et avec
la transparence nécessaire notamment
pour le parlement il n'y est pas en
revanche au travers de cette remise en
cause parfois de la confidentialité de
risque de danger pour l'ensemble de nos
agents à l'intérieur comme à l'extérieur
parce qu'après tout ils défendent eux
aussi et l'état et la république
merci monsieur le ministre ce président
monsieur le ministre je je partage au
fond ce que vous venez de dire est
notamment dans votre introduction il ya
un besoin de transparence et nos grandes
démocraties notamment le parlement
doivent pouvoir traiter ces questions de
renseignement de manière sereine et avec
le souci du respect de la loi et en même
temps nous devons protéger ses agents
qui serve les intérêts fondamentaux de
notre pays
le rapport de jean jacques urvoas du
président la commission des lois à
l'assemblée vient d'être remis nous faut
peu de temps pour en tirer toutes les
conclusions mais en tout cas je vais
vous dire que il me semble et je vais
dans le sens du rapport nécessaire en
premier lieu de renforcer les bases
juridiques de l'action des services de
renseignement la plupart des grandes
démocraties ont engagé le telle démarche
en mettant en place des outils qui sont
protecteurs et il faut reconnaître que
notre pays encore du mal à les concevoir
et c'est cet équilibre là qu'il nous
faut évidemment trouver de ce point de
vue là les conclusions de la mission et
aux voies sont ambitieuses et me
semble-t-il bienvenue même si après il
faut les examiner dans le détail elle
pose les jalons d'une réflexion qui
pourrait opportunément être mené sur ce
sujet là dans les prochains mois c'est
d'ailleurs ce que nous avions commencé à
faire dans le cadre de la loi
antiterroriste
d'autres questions se posent sur les
bases juridiques de l'action des
services de renseignement tels que par
exemple porte unités nous en avions
discuté ici même de faire évoluer la loi
de 1881 dont chacun pourra convenir qu
elle n'offre pas un cadre adapté aux
réalités du monde contemporain
je pense aux notes de prescription de
publicité sur internet et les réseaux
sociaux par exemple les services de
renseignements demandes ses bases
juridiques davantage solidifier et qui
les protège
il y à une demande de transparence des
du parlement et de la société et en même
temps nous devons protéger ses agents et
permettent surtout l'efficacité des
services qui demande évidemment du
secret elle est là la ligne de crête que
nous devons trouver ensemble
merci monsieur roger karoutchi très très
brièvement monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre c'est évident que
c'est une ligne de crête autant le
parlement comme l'opinion veut le savoir
autant nous savons bien que ceux qui
décident ce qui donne les instructions
ont aussi besoin souvent beaucoup de
secrets de discrétion
si on veut l'efficacité donc
naturellement il ya un équilibre à
trouver
et bien entendu nous serons extrêmement
vigilants sur cet équilibre pour ne pas
remettre en cause la sécurité la
confidentialité et l'efficacité de nos
agents merci la parole à présent
monsieur alain richard pour le groupe
socialiste dans monsieur le ministre
votre administration et vous-même venait
d'apporter une contribution évidemment
substantiels à la réalisation du livre
blanc de la défense et de la sécurité
nationale et ceux ci étaient comme c'est
naturel l'occasion de préciser
d'actualiser au fond ce que sont les
grands traits de la menace actuelle en
matière de terrorisme
donc en peu de mots compte tenu des
particularités de l'exercice
comment décririez-vous comment
résumeriez vous font les points
marquants de l'évolution récente de la
menace terroriste sur le sol français
sur les sur la population française et
les priorités sur lesquelles vous
insisterez dans les moyens disponibles
et d'henri dans le cadre de la loi pour
renforcer la protection de nos
concitoyens et de nos intérêts nationaux
et avoue quelques indications à nous
donner sur la progression de notre
coopération en la matière avec nos
partenaires européens et atlantique le
seul ministre vous à la parole
le président monsieur le ministre la
menace terroriste
elle est élevée elle est là il faut la
l'appréhender ainsi elle nécessite
beaucoup de vigilance de la mobilisation
et des moyens supplémentaires cela vient
d'être dit nous faisons face à une
menace je le rappelais il ya un instant
que nous connaissons déjà
celle qui peut venir de letea celle qui
peut venir d'un certain nombre de
groupes voyons bien quelles sont les
conséquences des activités par exemple
du pkk sur notre sol même si nous
suivons avec intérêt les évolutions d'un
dialogue avec la turquie
et puis les menaces qui existent y
compris que nous concerne notre sol
venant de l'ultra droite ou de l'ultra
gauche mais il ya cette menace
djihadiste elle est incontestable et
nous faisons face à la fois à l'ennemi
extérieur et nous devons le combattent
dans une coopération accrue et de très
grande qualité avec nos principaux
partenaires et notamment au niveau
européen même s'il ya sans doute des
progrès à accomplir cette menace
extérieure elle existe elle est
alimentée par les conflits qui existent
dans le monde et que vous suivez
parfaitement elle a était évidemment
sensiblement accru avec l'intervention
de la france nécessaire indispensable au
mali et je veux saluer de ce point de
vue là là aussi la coopération avec les
pays du maghreb ou de l'afrique de
l'ouest
et puis nous faisons face aussi un
ennemi intérieur avec un lien évidemment
avec ces conflits et c'est ce que nous
évoquions tout à l'heure avec madame
desbassyns sur la nécessité de mettre en
place tous les outils pour lutter contre
cette radicalisation
mais cela nécessite évidemment un
travail très fin entre le hérie
l'information générale nos services de
police et de gendarmerie
la société tout simplement parce que il
y as we des loups solitaires des
processus de radicalisation le web qui
participe ce qui se passe dans un
certain nombre de mosquées dans le
milieu carcéral qui nous oblige à être
évidemment très vigilant et c'est ces
individus hybride à la fois au niveau
national comme au niveau international
qui font qu'aujourd'hui la menace est
toutes très
particulière sans doute encore plus
difficile à appréhender et nécessite
beaucoup de vigilance
merci monsieur alain richer si vous
souhaitez réagir
juste quelques mots monsieur le
président pour rendre hommage à la
finesse et en même temps à la capacité
du minist de cerner l'essentiel je crois
que c'est très très représentatif de la
réalité et je crois que ça crée à tout
le monde d je pense en particulier aux
collègues élus locaux des obligations de
faciliter leur enseignement au quotidien
dans cette situation en effet de
dispersion et de d'individualisation
sous certaines formes de la menace il
est important qu'une espèce de détection
précoce puisse être fait pour aider les
services de terrain de la police
nationale je sais que eux ont la
motivation ils ont des instructions pour
travailler de cette façon je crois que
le le tissu du service public tout
simplement doit contribuer je crois que
nous sommes nombreux ici à être
convaincu que c'est nécessaire mais un
merci la parole à monsieur christian
cambon pour le groupe ump
c'est monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre un peu plus d'un an s'est
écoulé depuis le dramatique attentat de
toulouse a été évoquée ici tout cet
après-midi et la ferme et ran on finit
pas d'alimenter les controverses et le
débat sur les supposés aurait l'insu
imperfections de notre système intérieur
de protection mais dans le même temps en
l'espace d'un an le contexte a
considérablement changé il s'est hélas
dégrader la situation au sahel et plus
particulièrement au mali a contraint la
france à intervenir militairement dans
les conditions que l'on sait ce faisant
notre pays c'est aussi exposés à des
risques de représailles particulièrement
élevé de fait les appels de chefs
djihadistes à frapper les intérêts
français partout dans le monde commence
à être suivi d'effets j'en veux pour
preuve
l'attentât contre notre ambassade à
tripoli et la tentative d'attentât
contre notre ambassade au caire
tous ceux ci sont des signes des signes
dallaire des signes de danger sur les
risques que la france en cours de voir
son propre territoire
touchée par ces attentats autour de nous
les exemples font frémir
après l'algérie à in aménas ce les états
unis à boston la turquie dernièrement
tout ceci montre que des états
particulièrement bien armé pour lutter
contre le terrorisme aveugle peuvent
être eux aussi touchés en leur coeur un
an un djihadiste français cela a été
évoqué a été interpellé il appelait à
importer sur notre territoire la guerre
sainte et ça nous appelle ça nous
rappelle une réalité nouvelle de jeunes
français vont s'entraîner dans des camps
en afghanistan au pakistan
ils vont recevoir des formations au
jihad dans ces pays où les groupes
terroristes sont implantés et ils
peuvent comme meira comme ça s'est passé
à boston à londres à madrid dans des
attentats précédents trouver sur le
territoire national des complicités
mais aussi des approvisionnements en
armes et en explosifs alors face à ces
dangers laisse nos concitoyens sont
réellement inquiet aussi monsieur le
ministre je voudrais simplement savoir
si le niveau de coopération européenne
est suffisant pour nous aider à traquer
l'ensemble de ces individus
car la réponse ne peut pas être
nationale la france est particulièrement
exposé l'europe doit nous aider
quelle est l'action que vous menez dans
ce sens merci le second but adverse
ce président monsieur le sénateur
christian cambon là aussi en écho à des
propos très juste peut-être quelques
chiffres depuis 2001 au total plus de
200 volontaires ont quitté la france
pour s'engager dans une filière
jihadiste
dix sept sont morts dans les zones de
combat et 69 de ces personnes séjournent
actuellement sur notre territoire le
développement des départs de volontaires
vers la syrie constituent en revanche à
partir de 2012 une véritable rupture
plus d'une centaine de personnes se sont
rendues sur ce territoire
sur ce théâtre de guerre en seulement un
an et demi ce contingent atteint en
effet 60% du total des volontaires et on
constate y compris le départ d'
individus mineurs sans expérience
religieuse qui s'engagent sur un coup de
tête
ce phénomène touche d'autres pays
c'est vrai au maghreb mais c'est vrai en
europe ce qui nous amène à renforcer je
pense
nos amis belges notre coopération les
échanges d'informations évidemment un
travail commun mais il ya là un
véritable danger pour nous et pour nos
intérêts et nous faisons face évidemment
par l'engagement des de nos services de
renseignement
je vous donne un autre chiffre 78
personnes ont été interpellées par là
des séries dans le cadre de la lutte
antiterroriste en 2012 contre 47 en 2011
et depuis le début de l'année se
chiffrer l'aide s'élève déjà trente huit
interpellations ont donné lieu à 12
écrou
cela veut bien dire et cela fait écho
aussi aux propos du sénateur alain
richard qui lie à une menace et qu elle
est concrète ne relève pas uniquement du
fantasme ou de la recherche de
stigmatisation elle repose sur des faits
réels
la situation très dégradée au sel en
libye en tunisie
bien évidemment en syrie et sur des
filières que nous devons combattre à
travers la coopération internationale et
le travail de le service de
renseignement merci mon cher collègue
monsieur christian cambon oui je
voudrais remercier le ministre à la fois
des données statistiques qui vient de
nous fournir et de la prise en compte de
ce risque qui est bien à elle qui est
bien réel temps juste revenir sur un
point la nécessité qu'il y à encore que
l'ensemble des pays européens se trouve
véritablement mobilisé peut-être une
conférence des ministres européens sur
ce thème serait le bienvenu car le
danger peut se produire est pas et et
faire irruption par de très nombreuses
frontières qui sont encore trop lâche en
europe merci vue sioniste
merci monsieur andré reichardt pour le
groupe ump seuls ministres sur le
président mes chers collègues
suite à la tuerie de toulouse de mars
de nombreuses propositions avaient été
faites par chacun des candidats à
l'élection présidentielle afin que nous
n'ayons pas à revivre de tels événements
parmi ces propositions beaucoup
portaient sur l' influence grandissante
d'internet dans le développement des
groupes terroristes
le profil de mohamed merah qui filmait
ses crimes
les publier sur le net celui des
terroristes de boston confirme et de
loin cette analyse ainsi l'utilisation
des moyens internet permet aujourd'hui à
ces groupuscules de recruter des
jihadistes improvisé mais aussi de
diffuser leur propagande parmi les
réseaux sociaux les plus utilisés les
plus accessibles dont twitter facebook
youtube et bi bien d'autres faut-il
rappeler d'ailleurs tout le monde le
sait que certains magazines en ligne
vont jusqu'à illustrer la fabrication
d'explosifs à ce sujet l'article 1er de
la loi de la loi du 21 décembre 2012 a
prévu de prolonger jusqu'au 31 décembre
l'accès préventif des services chargés
de la lutte contre le terrorisme aux
données techniques recueillies dans les
communications électroniques ou lors de
l'accès à internet
ce dispositif que la précédente majorité
avait autorisé en 2006 et qui devait
s'achever en 2012 fin 2012 a donc été
renouvelé
c'est une excellente chose pourtant il
faut bien admettre que dans ce domaine
la lutte contre le terrorisme est loin
d'être abouti tant qu'il reste
d'obstacles à franchir
du fait notamment de la difficulté
technique de maîtriser les flux internet
si j'aimerais savoir monsieur le
ministre quels sont aujourd'hui les
orientations du gouvernement quant à la
politique à mener en ce qui concerne le
contrôle de certains réseaux internet
par les groupuscules terroristes
quels moyens pourrait être mise en
oeuvre pour limiter leurs actions et
qu'est ce qui nous empêche aujourd'hui
d'approfondir cette question y at il des
moyens humains à m en complément y at il
des moyens techniques à mettre en
complément ces interrogations sont
d'autant plus importantes qu internet
présentent un risque accru dans la
radicalisation des individus d'abord en
accentuant le relâchement de leurs
propres liens sociaux individuels et
c'est à mon avis gravissime
ensuite en leur fournissant les moyens
d'agir et enfin en glorifiant leurs
crimes
merci monsieur le ministre le président
monsieur le sénateur andré reichardt
oui il va là aussi et vous l'avez
souligné dans ce débat les uns les
autres
internet est devenu un vecteur de
propagande de radicalisation et du
recrutement pour la mouvance terroriste
et internet fait l'objet d'une
surveillance vigilante delà des séries
afin d'y détecter les activités de la
mouvance terroriste
la loi vous l'avez souligné prévoit
plusieurs moyens destinés à lutter
contre l' usage d'internet et des
réseaux de communications électroniques
à des fins terroristes
il ya des moyens d'en quête aussi qui
sont utilisés la loi de 2012 renforce
l'arsenal juridique dans la lutte contre
la propagande terroriste sur internet
mais nous faut sans cesse nous adapter
parce que le terrorisme a souvent un
train d' avance par rapport à la loi et
aux moyens légaux de l'état gelées
souligné il y a un instant d'autres
évolutions du cadre juridique de la
lutte contre le cyber terrorisme seront
sans aucun doute nécessaire à l'avenir
et ils devront compléter notre arsenal
juridique comme je m'étais engagé un
travail interministériel est en cours
avec les ministères de la justice des
finances de l'économie numérique pour
adapter notre droit qui doit évoluer nos
moyens d'investigation mais aussi nos
organisations méthodes de travail aux
enjeux de la cybercriminalité ça ne
concerne pas d'ailleurs que le
terrorisme elles devront bien sûr
concilier l'efficacité de la prévention
et le respect des libertés individuelles
elle nous oblige aussi à une très grande
coopération européenne et là je crois
que il y a les bases d'un accord entre
les pays de l'union et nous obliger à un
dialogue avec nos amis américains qui
sur ces questions là ne ne suivent pas
toujours
du fait de leurs amendements numéro 1 et
sur le contrôle de l'internet il me
semble que c'est un des principaux
enjeux des prochains mois dans les
discussions avec nos partenaires
monsieur andré reichardt si vous le
souhaitez oui pour remercier monsieur
mise cette réponse je voudrais
naturellement dire que face à la menace
terroriste actuelle cette lutte contre
le terrorisme doit être érigées en
véritables priorités nationales et à cet
égard
à cet égard tout ce qui peut être fait
pour améliorer notre efficacité en ce
qui concerne le contrôle des flux
internet doit être fait je pense que
dans le cadre de cette priorité
nationale des moyens particuliers
doivent être affectés en la matière et
je vous remercie de bien vouloir le
prendre
merci voilà monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je vais suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise
16h pour l'examen de la suite de la
proposition de loi permettant
l'instauration effet qu'il donne passe
navigo unique aux tarifs des zones 1 et
2 la séance est suspendue
voilà pour cette séance de questions
cribles thématiques consacrées à la
lutte contre le terrorisme
restez avec nous émission spéciale à
suivre sur la conférence de presse de
françois hollande c'est à suivre tout de
suite sur les chaînes parlementaires bon
après midi à tous